الاتراك لعبوا ورقه الاستقرار والامن
بالجوله الاولى اي انهم رفضوا وضع ثقتهم
بتحالف معارض متعدد الاطراف والمصالح
استطلاعات الراي الاوليه جاءت خادعه فقد
اظهرت ان الناخبين على وشك اداره ظهورها
لنزعه رجب طيب اردوغان الى ان هذا التفاؤل
كان في غير محل فالازمه الاقتصاديه
والزلزال المدمر ورقتاه كلتش دار اوغلو
الاساسيتان لم تفلحا وتحققا الاثار
المتوقعه على الرغم من الاقتصاد المتعثر
اظهرت تصويت ارتخاء قبضه اردوغان على
السلطه ولكن ليس انكسارها صحيفه
البريطانيه اكدت ان المعارضه ستحتاج الى
شق طريقها بين الناخبين الوطنيين الاقل
ثراء خارج المدن للنجاح بجوله الاعاده
سينما ان مهمه تحالف كلتش دار اوغلو صعبه
للغايه معا حياز وسائل الاعلام باغلبيه
ساحقه لصالح اردوغان وعقد ثالث من حكمه
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات